this is a fox news alert a bus of
illegal immigrants from the del rio
sector down in texas arriving now in
washington d.c just a few moments ago
right here's another family we're
raising fox news contributor karl rove
joins us now
carl the governor is making good on his
promise
he says if you have illegal immigrants
here we're going to put him in
washington d.c
what do you think of the what was
witnessing right now
well it's a demonstration of how
desperate the situation is along the
texas border look we're spending
tens of millions of dollars of texas
revenue to provide national guardsmen to
fill the holes along the border that the
border patrol says it doesn't have
enough federal personnel to cover so
when is the federal government
government going to step up and uphold
its responsibility they don't care this
thing has been this thing's been called
a stunt but it is about the only way
that we can sort of grab the attention
of the of the of the nation and of the
federal government and say meet your
responsibilities to control the border
and you know what carl this is just a
preview of coming attractions because
when they left title 42 uh you know they
are suggesting not only perhaps 18 000
migrants into the country a day but
they're saying there could be 60
000
within the first couple of hours and
that means they're going to just stream
across and they're going to be standing
around and they're going to be those
images of thousands of people
which is the one thing according to the
newspapers that the biden administration
doesn't want because that's the image
they don't want people to see before the
midterms look what the biden
administration did
yeah and look it's not just the images
these people are the uncompensated care
that is having to be provided by border
hospitals the social service
network that is being stressed to the
limit that the petty crime that is
happening when these people come across
the border and are desperate for shelter
and food and water all of these things
are being felt up and down the border
there's a political impact of this this
is why the texas southern border was one
of the most
significant areas of movement from
democrat to republican between 20 uh
between 2016 and 2020 because they're
blaming the people the democrats for
having an open border mindset and and
hold them responsible for it what
happens to these people i'm sorry that's
okay um so the white house said this was
going to be this is just a gimmick
they're just saying that no they're not
they're actually doing this and so is
ron desantis they just approved 12
million dollars to do the same thing
down in the state of florida so when it
comes to the midterms and i know that
you talked to so many people you're
involved in in politics heavily when you
talk to independents what do they say
about this issue immigration how will
they vote in november
well the president's ratings on this are
poor they're like the same on the
economy and and uh
and crime they're lousy and uh
what's going to happen to the democrats
if this as this issue gets more
prominent uh as the summer and fall go
on i mean it's it's not going to be
helpful to the democrats and
particularly when they've got voices
like they've got here there there's a
there's a primary battle and in a
district that that is on the border from
laredo uh there where the incumbent
democrat henry coyer is a moderate
democrat who who supports strong border
efforts his opponent is an open borders
person who's actually called for the
abolition of the border patrol and she
might win if henry cuellar goes down the
democrats will have a person on the
border who says get rid of the border
patrol they already have a guy who who's
going to be their nominee here in
central texas who led the effort to
defund the austin police department by a
third and called for the implosion
blowing up the city's police
headquarters is a sign of the new spirit
that is in austin so that's those kind
of candidates are going to dog other
democratic candidates all around the
country a couple of things going on uh
carl in particular uh when you talk
about what's happening at the border you
have a president that is just
disinterested in the story that came out
that he's saying who do i need to fire
to fix the border crisis do you believe
any of this dialogue even took place
as if the first time we had a border and
their reaction every time we brought up
is i propose comprehensive immigration
reform republicans don't want to bring
it up will that fly
no it won't and they're in charge and
they have to they have to get they have
to secure the border when you have
states like mine i repeat we're spending
tens of millions of dollars of state tax
dollars to do something that the federal
government is responsible for the
federal government under the
constitution is in charge of immigration
they're in charge of defending the
border and they won't do it right we're
having to do it with texas dollars texas
national guard and texas men and women
being taken away from their jobs and
their families in order to stand on the
border one of my best friends in austin
his son is there until october and to
hear the stories of what they go through
routinely every night
capturing dozens of of people who are
making their way across the the border
in the middle of the night and about the
mexican cartels lighting up the sky with
tracer rounds to let everybody know
they're there the instructions that
they're given about what happens if
they're shot at these are just amazing
to me and we're having to do it because
the federal government under this
president is refusing to control the
border you know carl what we're looking
at is a remarkable image if folks are
just joining us those those are people
those are migrants
from the del rio section of texas who
came into the country in the last couple
of days
governor abbott had said you know i'll
bust him to washington dc the white
house said that's a publicity stunt but
there they are they're dropped off at
400 north capital just a couple of
blocks with the iconic u.s capitol dome
behind him that this is gonna for if
you're in the cartel business this is a
great image because it's like look how
easy that was give us a thousand bucks
and we'll get you to the capitol
yeah and remember each one of these
people had to volunteer they they were
they'd the the state of texas could not
take them and put them on a bus
forcefully that they had to be given an
option do you want to get on a bus and
go to the nation's capital and will you
sign this waiver so we're not held
legally uh responsible for your decision
and they get on the bus and off they go
uh but but look
we we shouldn't be doing this we should
be turning them back to mexico i know
but that's the federal government's
responsibility and they're not taking a
waste of money do you realize how we
need that money yeah abbott doesn't have
the authority to send them back to their
own countries but he does have the
authority to send them within to another
place to another place and he did carl
thanks for joining us
you bet